these are in listen only mode
good afternoon everyone this is Mark
Albert editorinchief of modern machine
shop magazine Welcome to our webinar
sponsored by fanic fa America thank you
for joining us our topic this afternoon
is CNC programming Made Easy with annual
guide ey conversational program part one
overview and setup
without particular knowledge of G-Code
programming it is possible to generate
part programs on the shop floor by
answering simple questions phix manual
guide eye conversational programming
provides this capability for Milling
turning and Mill turn centers with fic
cnc's
this webinar will give an overview of
the functionality
of manual guide eye and we'll also
highlight several steps to setting up
the software efficiently setting up your
tool library and setting up both your
turning and Milling fixed forms by the
end of this webinar you will know all
the preliminary work you need to do
prior to starting to create a new
program
our presenter today is jod Michaels is
end user account manager for fanic fa
America jod Michaels Focus is on
servicing and supporting and users to
maximize their productivity with the use
of phic cnc's
jod has 35 years experience in the
Machine Tool industry with various
positions in sales support Automotive
applications and training at Machine
Tool Builders and users and CNC
suppliers he is a true expert on CNC
programming and the functionality setup
and use of manual guide ey
as we listen to Jud during the
presentation please feel free to share
your questions with us by typing them in
the questions pane on your control panel
they will answer these questions at the
end of the presentation
this webinar is being recorded so you'll
be able to view the entire program
online later thanks again for taking
time to be with us for the Live program
here's Jody
thank you Mark uh good good afternoon
everyone as Mark said today we're doing
a manual guide eye part one overview and
setup I just want to let you know that
it is part one and as Mark said it is
about the overview and the setup we'll
do a overview of all the cycles and then
a setup of our tool data and then also
also all of our fix forms and then next
month we'll do one on a lathe program
and then in March we'll do a Milling
program so it will be a three-part
setup for this today's just the overview
in the setup
and one of the first things we need to
talk about is what exactly is manual
guide eye well what manual guide eye is
it's a powerful onboard conversational
programming system that is available
that uses intuitive Machining Cycles
both turning and Milling they use one
screen to fully program a part you can
check the part using simulation
set up your tooling your work piece
offsets and then actually machine the
part from within that system and it's
used on a wide variety of lays both
vertical horizontal inverted twin
spindles and then also Machining centers
both vertical horizontal and all
different types of machines that are
built by a variety of Manufacturers from
all over the world
what manual guide. I does it generates a
G-Code form map program that you can
store for later use also from within the
system you can import offline gcode
programs into the system and run those
and also simulate those within manual
guide eye also fanic does have something
called FC guide which is fanic CNC
software running on PC like your desktop
or a laptop which includes support for
manual guide eye and it's a great tool
not only for actually doing the program
but also for training your operators or
your programmers or whatever to actually
use the machine
now some of the benefits of manual guide
eye there's five of them that I try to
extol all the time about manual guide
eye and these aren't in any particular
order of importance or anything like
that but the number one thing is ease of
use and the reason I say that as we go
through this overview of all the Cycles
within manual guide eye you're going to
see that all of these different Cycles
are very similar they're very similar as
you set one up you have your cutting
conditions your detail data and then any
geometry associated with each cycle but
as you can see once we go through those
they're very similar that's very
important for your operators once they
get acclimated to one way that it's set
up the next one will be very easy number
two flexibility and the reason I say
that is all of us that are listening in
today or most of us we're all
programmers or operators walk or
whatever and we've all got a certain way
that we do things like when we do a tool
change or when we do go to a clearance
position we've all got a certain idea of
how we want to do that with manual guide
eye you can set it up the way you want
to do it not the way I want to do it or
the way your boss wants to do it the way
you want to program it you can set it up
that way so it's very flexible
also manual guide ey it's a learning
tool as you make programs and produce
all these g-codes when you're in the
edit mode and you scroll down through a
particular program and put the uh the
cursor over a certain spot it will give
you an explanation of what that G-Code
is or what that mcode is so that very
good for your operators or your
programmers that might not necessarily
know what all these g-codes are you'll
give them an explanation of that
number four you can put gcode and
conversational into one program you
don't have have to have separate
programs for the conversational or for
the gcode you can mix and match it you
can make a program offline on a cam
system import it into manual guide eye
and then you could add a conversational
cycle within that that's a very very
powerful part of this tool and also
simulation you've got the capability of
simulating both the conversational
programs and a G-Code program as long as
you have your tool data set up that
matches with your cam system software
you can simulate the program right
within manual guide eye
now some of the secrets for success for
manual guide eye these are critical that
you get these set up ahead of time
before you actually try to do your
programs because it's going to save you
a lot of Heartache later you'll get
alarms that you don't don't understand
what they mean if you go through these
two steps prior to starting and what
we're concentrating on today is lathe
programming we'll go into Mill later but
today is a lathe program
so that's all we're talking about today
the tool offset and the tool data Pages
associated ated with the lathe package
it's important that you set those up
correctly the tool types and all the
information that goes with each
particular tool then number two you set
up a set of fix forms that fit your
needs as we discussed before where the
flexibility where you set this up where
the fixed forms are what you want the
way you want to start a program the way
you go to do a tool change way you start
spindle Make them set up fit your needs
now to actually start manual guide eye
all Builders sort of do this differently
there's a a vast array of selections
what button we push to start manual
guide eye well most of the machines I've
done training on most of them either use
the graph function key or the custom
function key function key to actually
access manual guide eye and and what
we're showing here is an MDI panel from
the mill
and then the next one is an MDI panel
from a zero I TV control for a l and
it's got arrows pointing to the the spot
you push the custom button here or the
graph button and that gives you access
to manual guide eye once you press those
buttons it takes it to this screen it's
called the allinone screen on the
allinone screen it'll be in Colum
and you have a variety of information on
that screen you still got your your uh
position screen it'll show your uh
machine position your absolute position
or your relative position
it'll show the
active program it'll show the active
tool the active feed rate the active
spindle speed if there is a spindle
command associated with it load meters
and then all your various soft keys down
on the bottom
our next screen is just a little bit
better screen and it shows it a little
better where it shows all of our
different soft keys these are soft keys
at the bottom of the the control
here's our actual position our distance
go our spindle speed
and then once you get into your own one
screen you can then navigate the menus
within manual guide eye and you can go
to a variety of different modes you can
go to auto edit MDI and Jog modes plus
your MPG then page in between the
screens using the two arrow keys the
left arrow and the right arrow which I
call the left and right shift keys and
that's just what I call them just so for
your information as we go through the
rest of this today that's what I mean by
right and left shift for the two arrow
keys now at this point what we're going
to do on I'm going to change screens go
into NC guide which is our offline
software where we can simulate uh a
total control
I'm going to change screen
and go to NC guide the NC guide iceone
shown here as you can see this is a
phanic series zeroi Model D control this
is set up for a and what we're going to
do now and we're in in the edit mode as
you can see up here and what we're going
to do is go a right shift because what
we want to look at we're going to do an
overview of the cycles for turning and
you can see it shows a little turning
tool with a turning type part and we've
got three selections here we got start
cycle and end and we're gonna go look
and see what's in start if you press
that soft key it takes you into this you
have two TS
the start lines and this will be the
fixed forms that are in your tab one
and also if we Arrow over we have blank
definition this is important because
typically at start of the program you'll
do a blank definition and this is
basically for the simulation for when it
does the simulation it'll show a part
that's representative of the of the
piece of stock that you're Machining
but again this is very simple step just
fill in blanks if you select the blank
again it's just it asks for a diameter
the length the work origin and Z
very simple very simple
and then cancel out of that and now what
we're going to do we're gonna go into a
brief overview of the different Cycles
On the Turning mode we go into cycle and
we've got five different selections here
the software the way I've got it set up
you got whole Machining
you've got turning you got residual
Machining
turn grooving and threading those are
your five different selections for
turning and I'm just going to pick one
just as our first example because again
this is just an overview of the
different Cycles
if we select drilling
it takes you into a drilling cycle and
see and it shows a picture of what it's
doing and it also will show it has the
queue highlighted the first thing it
asked for is a pecking cut dep and we're
on cutting conditions for drilling and
you can see next to this it has an aster
anytime a cycle has a field with an
aster next to it you don't have to
answer that information it's optional
but in the example I have here I did I
did answer that part of it so what it's
asking for is pecking cut depth and you
can see it has Q highlighted so that's
like if you're doing a g83 three drill
Cycles where you want the drill to fully
retract that's what it's asking the
amount of each pack
then the go past am Mount that's just to
allow for the angle on the drill the
clearance that's like an R plane at the
start of a drill cycle your feed rate
dwell time again that has an aster you
do not have to answer that information
but that's like dwell time at the bottom
of the hole if you wanted to Dell for a
part of a second you could put that in
and then the approach motion anytime the
software will give you answers to any of
these fields of these soft keys down
here at the bottom
so you got three different selections
you got a vector move move an X and then
Z or then Z and then X so you got three
different selections
and then to to get to the next tab we
just use our Arrow key then it asks for
a base position in Z that's just ask
asking what the front of the part is
then the next one is your cut depth and
as you can see from the screen you have
a minus or a plus
it needs to have either a minus or a
plus there and the reason it does that
is this software is used on a variety of
machines so this could be a machine
where you'd have a left and a right
spindle so when you would drill on the
left spindle you put minus if you drill
on the right spindle you put plus
so that's very simple then it also has
detail data and again all four of these
have Asters next to them so you do not
always have to answer that information
but what this detail is is say you had a
very large drill and you wanted to start
it out at a much slower feed rate than
what you would actually want it once it
got fully engaged that's what this is
for to where you can start at a slower
feed rate and then increasingly make it
faster so that's what a drill cycle
looks like and then to get out of that
we just press cancel it takes us back to
our turning cycles and then we can just
page over and look at a turning cycle
and you got a lot of different
selections you got roughing semi
finishing
then rough and finish so you have 12
different selections here but we're just
going to pick one we'll select counter r
and again it's just fill in the blanks
just like the drilling cycle whenever
you put information into it like here
we'll just go z
z minus then it's asking for a cut down
and you can see it highlights Q so that
it's a depth of cut per size this is a
radial amount it's very important that
you remember that it's a radial amount
see and once you type in a value there
0.1 then you press input right here it's
important that you remember that because
if you try to press insert here or
insert there before you put all the
information in you'll get this alarm
short input data whenever you see that
alarm that means that you've tried to
input the cycle before you put all the
information in that's what that's for
then the next field is just x-axis
finish amount that's how much finish
stock per side that you're going to
leave in the x-axis
and then D is just the Finish amount
You' leave on shoulders or on the end of
the part then feed rate your straight
feed rate then the angled feed rate if
you're doing a relief you can slow that
down and then when it comes out of a
relief then you have detail data the
first one is first speed rate override
that's for like on a lath if you had
something chucked up in hard Jaws where
it was running out you'd have the
capability of slowing down that first
pass only the first pass then after that
it'll go back to your commanded feed
rate the cut rise method that's for when
you're turning over to a shoulder when
it feeds up to go back to the next move
you always want to use cut there because
otherwise it's going to leave big steps
on a shoulder and the rest are all just
clearance moves and then and your
approach motion like before then also
within turning this is a very nice
feature if you're running Chuck or work
where it's you have clearance at the end
of the part you can tell it to face the
end of the part you do not have to make
a a separate facing cycle you can do it
all within the Turning rough but as a
note of caution here you have to make
sure that you're not using a center in
the end of the part because it's going
to face all the way way down to x0 you
have to have clearance to where you can
get to the end of the part all the way
down to the center
so that's all the different
uh Fields within a rough turning cycle
as I said what's good about all these
they're very similar this looks just
like the drill cycle just fill in the
blanks
then we cancel out of that we go back
into our turning Cycles the next tab is
residual Machining
just to give you an explanation of what
that is say for instance we're turning a
part that has a large relief that only
one particular type of tool will fit
into a relief
what the software does as long as you
have your tools described right
it'll look and see if a tool has
clearance to get into that relief if it
doesn't it'll give you a little message
saying residual stock will be will
remain that tells you that you have to
go into this cycle and select that and
fill in the blanks just like before
again it's got Z minus z+ and it looks
just like a rough turning cycle exactly
the same field the software will
actually then go take that tool in the
one that will actually fit into that
profile
and go in and just take out the stock
that's left so that's residual machine
again as I said it looks exactly like
the other Cycles just fill in the blanks
all right our next one is turn groovy
again we'll select that
and it takes into our grooving site
again we have two tabs we have cut
conditions
and we have detail and again it's just
fill in the blank it has two different
types either Center cutting and that's
what you're typically going to use for a
a Groove cycle what it does it PS the
center of the groove out then goes to
each side and finishes it based on
whatever width you tell it
if you want to use layering what that
does it only takes layers out it'll go
down so far rough completely out go down
a little further and rough it completely
out that's how that works if we use
Center cutting then you can leave again
you can see both of these next two
Fields have asteris where you don't have
to answer that information you but you
can leave a certain amount of finish
stock a feed rate a pecking you can tell
it to pack where it just goes in so far
backs out for where we break a chip this
is very handy for Grooving because we've
all been down that road where we do a a
grooving cycle and we end up with a chip
that's about three miles long we don't
want that this is very powerful it gives
you a choice of where you can get around
at you can tell it how deep the gas and
then you could have it getting
progressively shallower the deeper the
groove get this is just a return amount
then the detail of a clearance like an R
plane a dwell then just see approach
motion and then how far it backs off
when it's in the the actual Groove cycle
and then once you define all that
then you have to go do a figure of a
group
you select that and again it's just fill
in the blank and what's good about it is
like here it's asking you where you're
defining the geometry of your group
either Z minus or z+ so it's just
depends on how your print is toleranced
whether it's giving a dimension to the
front of it so it makees makes it very
powerful you know a lot of them they
always go to the back of the group with
this you can go either way then another
good thing about the grooving
you've got the capability of on all four
corners
bottoms also where you can either Define
a champer or an arc or nothing you can
make a be Shar corner and then obviously
you can do multiple grooves you can
however many you want the pitch then
which direction they go whether it's Z
minus or B z+ based on the geometry of
your print
so that's that's the grooving cycles
and we go back then we go we've done our
grooving now threading again threading
is very simple fill in the blanks again
we select threading outer The Cutting
method that's just how you're it is
feeding the tool into the thread itself
and it defaults to single a single
amount and what that is that's like on
an engine when you've got your compound
set up on 30° and as you go in deeper
into the thread it's only cutting on the
leading edge of the insert that's what
it defaults to
but you got six six different ways of
feeding into it
the Finish amount you could leave a
particular amount of finish stock
or a particular number of finishing
passes
and then also you can have cut type you
can have number of passes or depth of
cut those are your two choices
I'm an old engine La guy so I'm used to
cut number I've got a my head how many
passes I want to take so I always use
that but some people always think in
depth of cut that's all right too it'll
work both ways
okay detail that's just for your
approach move you know whether want to
do a vector or one way or the other and
then just our clearance moves in x and z
then at the back of the thread also
so threading is very easy and once you
do the threading again you have to
define a thread figure
and from there you can go general which
can be a a tapered thread metric unified
OD tapered pipe threads or ID tapered
pipe threads so it's very powerful but
we're just going to show you the unified
we'll select that and again it's just
fill in the blanks saying is it a male
or a female thread the thread diameter
the thread start point in Z the threads
per anch we'll just put 16 in there just
for an example because I want to show
you this the length and it'll figure the
depth for you based on how many threads
per inch you put there if you press
calculate it'll come up with a radial
depth of the threat
also another thing I want to tell you
whenever there's a number associated
with an answer in a manual guide eye
field you can control W act as a
calculator so if we go down here and go
one/
then input that it'll do the math for
you so it's capable of doing any math
function that you know the symbol for
whether it's division multiplication
adding subtraction
tangent coent it'll do all that figuring
for you so that's important that you
know that
so at this point we're going to cancel
out of that because at this point we
sort of went through all of our
Cycles within turning so now I want to
go into our tool offset data
so at this point if we press right shift
twice three times we get to a sauce key
where it says T FS if we press that that
takes us into our tool offset table
and as you can see see we've got three
separate tasks we've got geometry offset
wear offset and Tool data and for manual
guide eye it's critical that you fill
out all of this data as much as you can
based on the information from the
tooling that you're actually loading
your turret up or your tool changer or
whatever you might have on your leg but
it's very important that you enter in
all this information all right in our
geometry offset
the first two fields are just your x and
z offset this is when you go measure
your tools using this or tool Setter or
whatever you might have on your La
so I don't have any values in there
because I don't really have a real
machine on my S so we're not really GNA
go over that at this point we'll go into
that in more detail next month when we
do the full La program
now we'll change a cursor as we
page over the next value that we need to
fill out is the radius and what that's
asking for on a turning tool is the
radius of the actual insert
so that's what it's asking for there I
know on my tool this is an 80 degree
left turning insert I'm using a 31,000
nose radius tool and where I get that
number from let's do this we're going to
get get out of NC guide for a moment
back into the PowerPoint presentation
and here it's saying tool geometry
and down at the bottom says the radius
of the insert R and the geometry of the
tool should only be inserted in the
geometry page of the offset register so
it's important you enter those and what
a factor for in the radius input on the
number of the insert that you're putting
in your tool there'll be a a number
associated with that usually it's four
letters and then three numbers the last
number is the radius of the the size of
the radius of the tool a number two is a
302nd radius a number one would be a
15,000 a number three would be a 47th
and so on so it's important that we know
what those are so that we put the
correct number in there all right
because otherwise if we if we had the
wrong number that there
the control is going to spit out that
information so it's very important that
we have the right number there all right
the next one's very important also the
virtual tip because what that's used for
is the orientation of the tool
the ones you're going to use the most
the number three is typically going to
be an OD turning to a number two will be
an IB boing bar
and number seven will be a drill those
are are going to be the three that you
use the most that's what you see on this
first page tools 1 through 7 we have a
three three three two a three and then
two seven so typically with that
that's what you want there and again
we're gonna jump out of this just
momentarily
just to show you some of the things some
of the where we get those answers
so orientation this is for a turret on
the top and see it shows
a turret here with a a Tre with that
orientation that's an OD turning tool a
number two would be a boring bar the
number seven would be drilling on the
center the number four as it shows in
this diagram would be a reverse turning
tool
the next one shows it a little better
and just describes it a little better
right external tools are number three
number two is Right internal tool the
number seven as you can see with be a
drill because it's on Center
all right this is to orientation based
on a bottom turn again it still uses the
same numbers for this little diagram
here the number three is still turning
tool the number two is still a boring
bar and number seven is still a drought
but it's very critical that we get that
information correct in this field
because otherwise the control is not
going to understand what you're going to
want to do and it's come up with alarms
that you might not understand so it's
very important that you know the correct
data to put in this field the virtual
tip all right it's critical
all right now as we cursor on over now
we're on the next tab the we offset
again the x and z axis this is just
where you fine tune your offsets so if
you're turning something with a close
tolerance and you want to offset your
tool to to allow for Tool wear this is
where you do do it x and z the radius
value you don't have to put a value here
in your wof set you only need to have it
in your geometry offset
the virtual tip this will automatically
pick up whatever you put in your
geometry offset so it's only necessary
to put it in once you don't have to put
it in several different times
all right now the next tab tool data
this information is very important for
manual guide eye because this is where
you tell it the type of tool you're
using the cut angle on the nose angle
the inserts and then also for the
simulation the setting key so the first
thing we go into is a tool type and it's
important you have this correct
because when you do an OD turning cycle
it needs to know that you're using a
general turning F and that's on our
first menu it we got General we got
threading grooving a button tool or a
straight tool like a neutral tool like
if you want to do profile
uh pulley GRS or something like that
that's what it has
we get a right shift that takes us to
our next set of tools these are our on
Center type tools for a lathe you have a
drill a champer a flat end maill a ball
noos in mail a half a reamer a boring
bar and a face now and if we get a right
shift one more time be have one other
tool this tool is like a a turning tool
that's like a grooving tool you can
Groove and turn and face [clears throat]
with it
so that's all of our different
selections
okay in my tool set up here well number
one it's a general tool that's the type
then setting as you can see here it's
got six 16 different selections this is
basically for your simulation what you
need to do is look at the tool that you
have in your particular machine and see
how it corresponds to these one through
16 and that's what you need to put there
that's what you need to put there
I've got a number one because as I said
I know mine it's an upper turret 80
degree turning to and so that looks like
a number one in these fields
all right now the next one cut angle and
nose angle these are very critical if we
put the wrong information here you get
all kinds of bad information when you
actually make the program as I said the
tool that I have in my machine it's an
80 degree Diamond
Tool
and with that type of tool it always has
five degrees of clearance on the front
side
so if it was perfectly Square it would
be 90 so you take 90 and add the five
degrees of clearance and that's where
you get the 95
and the nose angle is the actual shape
of the insert shape of the insert not
the uh clearance relief on the backside
but the actual shape of the insert
all right and at this point we're gonna
jump out of this just for a second again
to go back to our tool data that
actually shows our tool data and then
how What It Wants in our cutting angle
and nose angle this screen is from the
actual page in the fanic manual of where
it describes this but what it does it
draws a line that's parallel with the
holder width and that's where it comes
up with the angle and it shows all the
different settings
and then also this information is
provided by Seco but this is just some
information about some different types
of tools the ones you you're going to
use most often the first one is the 80
Dee you're going to use that very often
for roughing as you can see it's 95
degrees is the lead angle typically for
that type of tool
then the next two are 35 degrees and 55
degrees and both of those typically the
front angle clearance is three degrees
so you're going to have 93 degrees as
your front angle
then the last one is a Trigon and again
it's like the
the 80 degree type insert and it has a
five degrees of clearance so it's going
to be 95 degrees and then you put 80 in
the shape of the tool
now at this point we'll go back to NC
guide
so that's the type of information you on
these first four I've got turning tools
so 35 degree with a 93 degree
cut angle and 93 degrees with a 55 those
are all my turning tools basically a
rough a finish and a semi with those
tools you ought to be able to get in
almost anything then the next one's just
a boring bar but again you describe it
the same way
then to go on to some other tool when
you define it as a Groove that's a tool
type again you just pick out the setting
of what the tool that you have in your
machine looks like and what it wants is
a tip lidth the tip length and what
that's what it wants for a grooving tool
then for a drill all it asks for is the
orientation
based on your type of machine and then
the angle on the drill then also one
note for when you're doing this you need
to go back on a drill if you want it to
show up in the simulation you you do
have to put a radius value here because
then it will actually show that size
drill so it's important you put a value
in there for a drill in a tap you don't
have to put a lot of information just
the tool type has to be correct and then
the orientation
on a horizontal way that's typically
going to be a number two the left
spendal
then for drilling drilling threading you
don't have to put a lot of information
just the right tool toop
again the setting based on what your
tool looks like and then the angle on
your insert
very simple but it's critical that you
get this information correct beforehand
and chamfer tool General and then a a
flat end again just the orientation
so that that's all the information that
we typically would put into our tool
offset data
and then just to show you that's this is
what a typical tool offset screen once
you get all your tools set up what it
looks like you need to have all this
answered because otherwise you're gonna
have issues once you actually start
doing programming within Manu gu ey
so that's the tool dat it sort of went
over everything there now at this point
we want to go over our fixed forms we
want to talk about our fixed form
and when you first go into manual guide
eye this is your typical first screen
and edit if you go right shck and
there's a soft key fix forms and it
takes you into the fix forms that a
usually this might be empty in your
machine it's critical that you go in and
set up different fixed forms and just to
let you know form one
and form five they will always be the
ones that when you go into start or end
that's what form one and number five are
form one will be the start ones form
five will be the end and what you do you
just go in and set them up as you can
see I've got tool change start spindle
start lines tooling on whatever you want
to put there you just set it up however
you want as I said form one these are
start of the program type commands and
what I do in form two usually I set up
head speeds for different different
types of material as you can see I've
got mild steel I've got stainless steel
aluminum cast iron preheat treated brast
roughing then finished speed rates and
speed C speed for that also and number
three I've got drill Cycles tapping
Cycles turning Cycles threading Cycles
where if I don't want to use the Cycles
within manual guide ey I can just go use
these just paste them in form four I've
got calling up sub routine or do a G10
assign value type of thing or just
starting a spindle form five is just end
the program I've got a parts counter
macro
I can just paste that into any program
and then when you actually want to put
that within a program you just press
insert and it actually adds it to a
program
now I showed you my fixed forms and
after this is over if you need to
contact me contact me direct I can help
you with develop these fix forms but
then to actually make them yourself if
you goar right shift
until you see a soft key called settings
you go into that it takes you into the
basics where you can either set them up
for mailling or turning you select
turning select select that then it takes
you into this where you can actually go
in and make your own fixed forms and
again it's got form one two three four
five [snorts] you can have up to 10 in
each one based on the size if you want
ones that are bigger you can cut it down
to five if you want and you can see down
here you can go new alter or delete what
we're going to do here just to show you
how you make a new one we're going to go
down number 10 and delete that one
delete and see it says are you sure you
want to delete it so it's never going to
be one of these things where you
accidentally delete something because
you got to press the button twice in
order to delete it so what we're gonna
do we're gonna make a new one if you
press new it comes up with this and the
first thing it wants is the name of
whatever fixed form that you're
selecting and we're going to say
clockwise
with
coolant
press enter for input and then it says
registered sentence and I know that's
M13
and the block
insert
see it puts it in that
wherever the cursor is that's where it
is so we made a new one there so that's
how you go through and add six forms
to your actual manual guide eye
you just go through all the tabs and put
whatever you want in there like I said
these are ones I developed for myself I
understand what I want but again this
gets into that flexibility that we
talked to before you set these up
however you want
like I said different people want to do
things differently so it's very
important that you set these up the way
you want then to get out of that just go
to menu
cancel and we're right back into ncii
then one one quick thing I want to go
over right while I'm in this program as
you can see I got a cursor
over each particular spot in the program
and see when I put it over the M5 down
here at the bottom it says M5 spindle
stop I cursor down to G30 it comes up
and says okay G30 is a second third or
fourth reference position return
m30 it knows it's the end of program
g1900 that's cylinder blank figure
that's part of the the learning tool
that we talked about earlier also as you
page down through the program it'll tell
you what everything is g90 G40 is an
explanation of that
so at this point I've sort of covered
everything I want to cover today we'
went over our tool data we've went over
fix forms how how to create six forms so
at this point as I said at the beginning
we are going to have three different
part one part two part three so at this
point I'm gonna turn it back over to
mark for any questions we might have and
then thank you for attending today I've
enjoyed talking to you and I I'll help
you out however I can thank you
hey thanks Jody uh that that was a very
interesting presentation and I'm I'm
looking forward to the uh follow-up
programs as well um so let's look at
some of these uh questions here one I'm
going to start with one because it's
pretty basic and I'm sure we want to get
this um settled right away and the
question is is this a standalone unit or
can I add it to any fanic controller
oh no no it's it's you can add it to
existing as long as you have Hardware
that would support you know the memory
that it takes for manual guide eye you
could add it to controls that don't have
it
okay um early in the program one of our
attendees was interested in um showing a
roughing cycle for a hollow cylinder so
I don't know if maybe you can just touch
on that briefly uh now that we're this
far along but there may be some comments
that you'd like add on that particular
process that operation
they wanted to do a a roughing process
for a hollow roughing cycle for a hollow
cylinder
oh yeah that that's no problem I mean
it's just when you're doing a turning
cycle with a hollow hollow cylinder say
you're boring out the inside
and uh the last move that you would make
would actually go down to the smallest
size of that Hollow cylinder and then
the control would know that that was was
where the stock would would be removed
so it's very simple to do that it's just
based on the geometry that you described
that Hollow cylinder within the the
Turning cycle that's how you do that
okay thanks Jody um here's a question I
hope you know what they're asking what's
the difference between caps and manual
guide eye
oh okay caps okay uh cap that's what's
usually on the like the mate controls or
some of the
it's
it's not an orat version of manual guide
eye it still uses the same Cycles but it
doesn't have the same graphical front
end as what manual guide eye is it's
still got basically the same function
it's just not as pretty
hope that answers that question yeah but
it's still works it works exactly the
same way it just it doesn't have the
same Graphics interface on from okay
good all right Jody how about this one
um Can the G-Code output use g70 g71 g72
no I'm sorry say that again Mark didn't
okay can the G-Code output use g70 g71
g72
yes yes it can yes I can
it will use those Cycles yes it will use
that can you tell us what those Cycles
are just for those who may not be aware
of what those stand for oh yeah g70
that's a skny turn can cycle and a g71
is a rough multi-pass rough turning
cycle and then g72 is either you
typically either use like in grooving
rough turning rough grooving Cycles or
rough facing Cycles but it will use all
those
okay good um this question question U so
I should have similar cycle on fanic 31i
model that make sense to you Jody yes
okay yes yes yes you can have manual
guide eye on a 31 eye that's correct yes
okay
uh let's see here um
where do I get the software for the PC
NC guide in parentheses
does that question make sense to J not
exactly sure what they're looking for
yes that's the offline version of the
software that supports manual guide ey
and you should be able to get that
either from your dealer or call us
direct and
someplace like that wherever they bought
the machine should be able to to get
them in touch with the right person to
apprach your manual or MC guy okay
uh see what else we have here um
we have manual guide eye on a new
machine is it setup similar to what you
showed us today or will we need to set
up a lot of the menus
set up a lot of the menus
now it should it should look exactly
like what I showed today
it should be set up exactly like that
it's just a matter of getting to where
you navigate through all the different
screens of the right mode to be in the
right screen and that's just a matter I
think as we go through our different
webinars of you know teaching how to use
it that they'll be able to find the same
pages that I went through today okay um
do do any of your training tools have
any sample programs
yes yes yes they do there'll be samples
within those both a a G-Code type or you
know if they want to see a whole
uh manual guide eye program that was
made totally and conversational I'll
have a I'll have something like that too
a sample if that's what they need okay
um
let's see um
Jody this question how do I change the
shape of the blank
okay that's an easy one and we sort of
went over that just a little bit but if
if they look at the screen here if you
go to the start button
and then there's the blank key if you
just go or if you were in a program
either way like the program that I have
called up here if you arrow down to
where it says cylinder blank figure or
whatever figure you have you press the
alter button soft key there see it takes
it back to within that cycle then you
just like I have four and a quarter for
the D am if I'll put 5.0
input that and say alter
and see it change it in the program it's
very simple because the mistake a lot of
people do because what it does Mark it
always default to the last
blank figure that it had and a lot of
people don't actually put this in their
program so it's important number one you
put it in the program and that's how you
actually go in and change it
okay um let's see how about
um
this question um is there any possible
way to get more information
for engraving in Easy guide and I think
that is a uh looks like a custom version
on docson machines I don't know if
that's gonna help you with that
question or not yeah easy guy it is way
that because you know some of our
Builders do you know make it special for
them um and the engraving on manual
guide eye is very simple you know it's
just fill in the blanks but to be honest
I'm not totally familiar with way if
there's something different on the easy
guide than what I'm used to them Manu
I'm not sure what the differences are to
be honest I'll have to do research on
that but the engraving and standard
manual guide eye is very simple very
simp you just go in and tell it you know
what you want to say the size of the
letters and which direction you want to
go 0 90 180 or 270 degrees
okay um Jody some more questions are
popping in here I'm trying to keep up
with them um let's see um
is there any way to create balanced
turning using G6
using manual guide
balance turning using what what GK g68
g68
that help you yeah uh
I'm not sure I'm not sure to be honest
I've I've never tried using that I guess
it could be possible but I'm not sure
okay um I'll be perfectly honest yeah
well you know Jody with as detailed a
presentation as yours was we're going to
get some complex questions here so I'm
going to go through these and see if we
can answer them as best we can um this
question is how about complex Contours
how would you define this
well that's where when you go in to do a
turning figure Mark you get into
you can go in and you draw it and once
you select that it takes you into a
screen where you define the start point
I'm sort of shown it here and then you
have lines arcs clockwise arcs
counterclockwise corner radiuses and
like with a line you select line you got
all these different selection whether
the line's G right right up up left up
so you can draw complex figures as long
as you got a good print you're more than
capable of drawing it on manual guide on
and you it'll do tangent connections
so it'll pretty much do whatever you
want it's just based on like I said
number one having a good print and
somebody that understands a good PR
all right um Jody the question maybe
then is um just a general question can I
import geometry data into the software
maybe you could tell us how that's done
no you cannot you cannot
import like a dxf file or an Isis file
you actually have to type in the data
yourself at this point we don't have the
capability where we can import the
geometry from outside
okay okay um now here's a question from
a a listener um is it capable of part
probing
yes yes okay it it is capable of that
you can do probing where it will go in
and measure a boore or find a a feature
yes there are uh probing type Cycles
within Manu obviously
this is something where you have to go
in and set it up correctly there's a
little more setup associated with proing
type stuff than what there is with a the
basic turning and Milling stuff okay um
here's a good question how do I change
manual guide eye to inch most of my
inputs seem to seem like they are in
metric
well the you know on any stanic control
you got the capability of changing it
from inom metric so it's basically you
know the same way that you do it on a
standard St control you can use a gcode
[clears throat] do it or there's a in
your settings you can go in and change
it there
okay now just you know a further answer
to that question there's some things
that you have to set up where you have
to be in metric mode like in probing you
know when you go in and actually set up
the probe it'll tell you in there that
everything has to be done in metric
okay okay um Jody I want to keep going
on these questions I know we're getting
some some good questions here just a
reminder to everyone um if we can't get
to all the questions while we're on air
we'll get to those questions after the
the webinar is concluded so um nobody
get left out the webinar is being record
it's going to be available online so if
you can't stay for the whole session and
you can catch up later so let me get to
this question will NC guide work on
64-bit Windows
NC guide yes it should I believe I mean
yeah guide man yeah NC guide yes okay uh
let's see
um couple questions about u simulating a
program um one question was yeah can we
can we see a it says can you show a tool
path simulation example is that possible
for us sure I can do that here let me go
let me get rid of this
I sort of added something to this
program that I had as a sample if we
Auto then simulate siml
then just press and I'll just do a
single a block at a time where it will
be able to see a little better
and see when it it did it very quickly
obviously but because it does it faster
when you're on a computer than what
would actually do it on a machine
but you can see it comes up and it goes
through what it does when it's doing a
convers ational program mark it'll go
through and read all the geometry before
it actually goes into it see now there's
a tool it does a rough cut another rough
cut
I'm seeing it's showing the tool and I'm
showing it like it would be on a like a
vtl type machine that's how I gotta
figure it right now
see it's going all the way through and
cutting the entire part I'm just going
going block by block at this point then
if I press start then it'll do it much
faster and there's a simulation
okay okay thanks Judy that that really
does add to some of the things that
we've been talking about and looking at
um this question and I might this if I
can get to all the other questions let's
let's do this one how often is Factory
training available for manual guide eye
typically now depending on where you
want to do it obviously you know uh
because we only have so many trainers
that that we send out to do training in
the field usually at least once a
quarter we'll have manual guide eye
training I believe and Hopman Estates
then in some of the outlying offices
will'll have training classes
intermittently also and then you also
have the capability of paying to have
onsite training for main GUI
so at least once a quarter and then
based on if you'd want to have it at
your own facility we can can do it there
and try to set [snorts] up its time also
but that's you know that's that's all up
to the training department
okay um Jody I guess seeing that
simulation sparked a couple more
questions um one viewer wants to know
says I see the simulation is running
faster can we get the actual cycle times
yes when you have it on an actual
machine now because I don't have it set
up on mine but when you do when you go
into the O list
if you go right shift for each see how
it has time here cut time when you have
it set up totally in your machine it'll
actually give you a cut time and then
non-cut time like for doing tool changes
and everything like that yes it will do
like a Time study for you and I'm sure
that's what they're wondering yeah okay
that's good answer then Jody um here's
another question how can I define a tool
shape slash form
outside of manual guide eye for
simulation with my cam programs is that
possible
yeah because there's a uh certain data
so you can spit out all the data from
the tool off set within manual guide ey
and I believe with that we could
actually put it I think this is probably
somebody like with with Master cam or
something like that where they'd
actually want to input their tool data
into this
all right
it it it's cap you can it is capable of
doing that yes
okay there's nothing that I can show you
a sample of with what I have today
all right uh question here um when you
touch off the tools normally do you have
to input them again and or will the I
guide pull them into the setup
yes yes because this is the same data
that's on the CNC side
it it shares that that information when
you measure a tool it will pick up the
data from your standard tool offs set
screen
okay um
let's see uh
can I run manual guide eye programs from
the other program screen on the control
and I think jedy we're going to probably
make this the the lay question here so
can you uh give us an answer to that one
can I run gu okay yes you you can go to
the gcod side and press cycle start in
Auto and it would run the G-Code it
would run the conversational program yes
okay good all right um Jody again thank
you for presenting your your slides and
showing us the the workings of of uh the
the programming system this is really NE
neat and and it's a lot of detail here
um you know for those attending this
afternoon session you can contact fa
America if you'd like more information
and we're going to get that uh uh
contact information up on the screen
here
and so we really appreciate the time
everyone's taking with us this afternoon
and um we hope you found it worthwhile
stay tuned for uh the next installments
in this series here so thank you much
for
um my thanks to all those who arranged
this the session helped it go very
smoothly and this concludes our webinar
so have a great day everybody this is
Mark Albert at modern machine shop
magazine signing off